okay so this is the panel on the
interpolation and reportability and
causality
and
as we've already seen throughout the
last two talks this is a very
contentious topic and lots of things we
it's easy to disagree on
so uh
yeah so i'm happy to have uh join alex
here
and
let me start by asking
two
basic questions about causality
my first question is
is there is is it really a cause like
um
we are searching for the cause but
does that entity exist at all is it
defined at all before
and
my other question which is kind of
related is i think that there is a role
here to
human perception
what humans will say what humans will
accept
what humans can conceive
as a plausible cause
and what is the role of the human
perception
in our notions of
of causality
so
let me start with you alex that sounds
great i feel like i'm much less
knowledgeable about this so it's good
that yes the quality will improve over
time
um
yeah i mean i i guess
you know it it seems that
the
you know the framework of causality that
or i guess the frameworks for causality
have been defined at least in the
statistics world right if we think about
the name and ruby model or or pearl's
models
they are
focused very much on this notion of an
intervention
and
you know i think i i feel
relatively satisfied with a notion of
causality that
allows me to predict
uh
what the outcome will be
in a world where i apply an intervention
um and
this i think there are there are many
different places where this can be
problematic so for example if i'm doing
astrophysics and i claim that there's
some causal relationship between things
i am not going to be able to you know
fly in a spaceship and push a star into
a black hole or something
but
i
i think to the extent that we are
willing to agree and i guess this is
sort of the human
element of it uh
that
you know there is a notional
intervention
uh and
this is
the the outcomes of this are what we are
trying to predict right so there there's
something that at least in principle
could
uh really come to pass and we could
predict it before we see it
um then i'm sort of happy with that as a
notion of causality absolutely um it's a
very forward-looking notion though um so
i'm not exactly sure how to reconcile
that with something retrospective like
explaining why this particular thing
happened right because i mean i'm
looking at us here
and i'm seeing your beautiful black hair
and the white hair will join me and now
we can ask what is the reason that we
whatever remaining hair we have is white
and yours is black and if i say it's age
oh you cannot intervene on age you
cannot take someone and change their age
by keeping everything so isn't
so age is not the cause for white hair
so
um i'm going to start by copying out and
say that if we're looking for the reason
that something happened that we get that
this is like a a case where we're doing
a retrospective analysis i guess
right if we wanted to do a
forward-looking analysis we might say
um
right that
we we could try to predict the color of
my hair
if we
uh put all the cells in my body in the
state that they would be in after
you know some period of time
i mean i i actually think that age is
sort of an interesting question here
because there are all of these notions
of biological age that uh that folks in
uh like biological sciences or you talk
to somebody who's doing metabolomics uh
we'll we'll talk about um right and i
think that we're actually trying to
abstract
the mechanisms that we're thinking about
when we say that age is the cause of you
know this issue or that issue to you
know particular
uh
mechanisms that are going on inside of
cells
um and so i think we might not be able
to say that
you know the time since my birth is
something that we can intervene on but
we might be willing to agree that there
are some
intermediate factors that are actually
intervenable
um and arrive at a more
precise discussion of cause that way
yeah so
i guess i largely will talk so first let
me go back and say they're
you you know are there really causes
there could be multiple causes that just
make sure we're on the same page
but
you know
i think cause
i'm not sure what it means to say
there's really a cause
um
on the other hand it's an incredibly
useful construct
so you know whether in nature there are
really causes
i i don't know how to answer that but
but i can certainly say that that for
people to structure the world in terms
of causality
seems incredibly useful
you can see you know little kids
try to figure out causes right they play
with things over and over again see what
happens if they intervene in different
ways i think there's a good evolutionary
reason they're doing that it's a useful
way to understand the world
um so in terms of shy's you know
particular question about you know do we
want to call
age a cause
my answer is that it's a useful
construct and it's useful precisely for
the reasons that out alex said that that
uh if we think of age as a cause and
maybe we can't intervene
you know i wish we could
i'm 25 again
but but um
you know can we in
so what we what we're really looking at
we're using age as a as a high level you
know macro variable in some sense to
represent a bunch of features just as
alex said and if we think of age as a
cause it makes us think well what
specific things that seem to be highly
correlated with age can we maybe
intervene on to stop our hair from
turning white and falling out um
and and it's again a useful construct so
um
yeah let me stop there
yes go ahead so i read from nancy
cartwright's
paper said i think she defines
causation as
like you have enough evidence to act
so can we have the
channel to
discuss also it's not as a dichotomy yes
or no but it's really a continuous
spectrum that's i'm kind of holding
and then you see enough evidence and
then you decide that
like as joe is saying it's a useful
construct i have enough evidence i'm
gonna act on it
so it doesn't require to be true but
it's really
like precursor to action
okay so so being introduces
yet a third element it's not just a
question of our perception but it's also
a question of our ability to act
to cause a change
so let me first answer your second
question which i realized i didn't
answer you know in terms of our
perception so i want to go back to
david's talk
that that i think
um
a big deal in our models was the choice
of variables
and i think the choice of variables
is strongly influenced influenced by
what you can perceive and what you can
control so this is maybe coming back to
been a bit that there's this famous
story that that um i think is due to
actually denis
uh dennis hilton but i think is actually
french um uh and
there's an accident and of a road
accident people are asked what the cause
is
and the structural engineer says
oh the road was designed badly if there
hadn't been a sharp curve here he
wouldn't have had an accident the auto
mechanic says there was a problem with
the brakes the psychologist said the guy
broke up with his girlfriend he's
depressed um
the sociologist said you know there's a
pub near the highway he's been drinking
a lot
maybe because he was depressed
my point here is not that any of them is
wrong
but they're each structuring the world
in a way
where the variables it's not so much
what they perceive in this case but the
variables they feel they have control
over
so the structural engineer
talks about the cause being you know the
shape of the road because that's what he
feels he can control
um you know the psychologist talks about
the guy is the depressed because that's
what he feels or she feels station
control and so on that that
so if we think of this as a useful
construct
part of the construct says that the
variables that we choose of course
depend on what we perceive we don't want
to talk about a world you know in
in terms of variables that don't make
sense to us given our perceptions but
also we use variables that we feel like
we can control
because these are the ones we feel we
can intervene on but not in all cases if
i say that the tsunami caused some
destruction on the beach i cannot
control the tsunami i still say that the
tsunami is the cause and i cannot also
do it
we would say that quite often we say
things like that in the context of okay
what are we going to do to prevent a
tsunami from happening next time
right the the that identifying the
tsunami is a cause
i i think we have a desire to understand
the world in terms of causality so quite
independent of of changing the world i
mean okay i'll speak for myself you know
i like to understand why something
happened even if i have no hope in hell
of doing anything about it so right so i
grant that but still i think it's often
not unrelated to or at least you know
maybe evolutionarily that desire springs
from the feeling that if we understand
what the cause was maybe next time we
could do something about it so i'm not
sure to answer ben's question at least
from my perspective i don't find that a
useful definition in terms of working
with it formally
um but that's just me but i i do think
we
you know we definitely care about
causality in terms of how we can affect
the world so that
thinking of the extent to which we can
affect the world
is i think very useful i just wouldn't
call that the definition of causality
that's my taste that doesn't feel like
a useful definition to work with but but
i feel like where i stand it's very
useful i like the formal definition of
all the philosophical discussions but
from where i am it's very hard from this
simple example to translate to something
say what genes to intervene on to see
whether cardi
vascular health
right it's just not a simple and the
definition don't fit but this
evidence for action just speaks to me as
an imperial cultural scientist very
clearly i'm not sure they're that far
apart because i can say things like
what's the probability that this
intervention will cause that outcome
and i would be perfectly happy to say
that
but the thing is
we have multiple probability models i
can have 17 different models from
heterogeneous variety so it's not that
simple what's the probability either
okay that's fair and then you have this
um different randomized starting values
and you have different data
perturbations so quickly
what the probability means becomes
slippery
and then but in terms of evidence i'm
kind of on the quality side then they
make sense to me
it could be just me
not understanding all the fine
philosophical points but uh
i feel like there could be a good
like both could be useful see whether
the panelists will agree with me
and the only thing i want to protest is
when you think it could be me not
understanding the philosophical aspects
i would say that
if you do not understand those
philosophical aspects then it's a fault
of the philosophical argument
i wish i mean i have no problem
i'm not a philosopher but you want to
add something oh um no i i do think that
uh there's there's something to this in
terms of uh
uh
perhaps
uh
right trying to uh move back from
defining a very abstract concept of
causality to just saying that
uh
yeah this is
this is the information that i
need to reason about the implications of
a of an intervention um so i i can i can
see where the uh
yeah where the motivation for that
definition is coming from and i
i would like to
read more about it
yes
so one question i have was i take the
mic
someone like to volunteer to be the mic
runner
zach was great at it this morning
so i don't have to uh
bring it all the way back up
i mean
there feels to me like a bit of a
distinction between the notion of
explanation in terms of
interventions or causality that we've
just talked about now
and the notion of explanation that we
talked about in the morning in terms of
ai so thinking about this as a
mathematician i think okay suppose you
gave me some complicated looking
function and you said hey i noticed that
it takes a value equal to zero or very
close to zero at this point what's the
explanation now i might say oh my
explanation is that that function
actually factors as a product of a bunch
of
linear forms one of which vanishes at
that point like one of which is zero at
that point that feels to me like an
explanation
it has nothing to do with
intervention or causality or anything
we've talked about but in some way it
feels rather close to what we would be
saying if we explain
why a neuron that produced a certain
output so how do we square that is that
kind of explanation
what we're talking about at all this
afternoon or is it just like a different
thing that has the same word in it
yeah i think actually we touched on this
a little bit earlier today right when we
asked whether there's a relationship
between thinking about explaining a
model to learn something about the world
versus
thinking about
explaining a model to sort of simply
summarize what this complex black box is
doing so i guess it was like explaining
the model versus explaining the world
um
and i
in trying to formulate my talk i
struggled a lot with trying to figure
out which of those i wanted to talk
about because at least in my mind they
seem to be quite distinct things um
although right as we talked about this
morning there there seemed to be some
connections between them um but yeah i
think you're right to notice that
there's definitely a divide there
yeah so
so i was definitely focusing on on what
i would call a causal explanation
because
largely i think that's what people are
looking for in cases so i take your
point that that you know if if i'm
teaching mathematics and i want to say
okay why does why is this polynomial
zero a good way to think about it is it
factors into a bunch of linear terms and
and and sure it's at x equals three
that's zero
um
it's not
seems like a different flavor of
explanation
that
i can i try to blur that a little bit
sure um
because i do a bunch of work with
ecologists who are really interested in
mechanisms that maintain things like
biodiversity
and so let me imagine uh let me tell you
a story this kind of a simplification
what they do i've got a couple of
bacteria species that eat the same
set of nutrients in a petri dish
but one of them is active during
daylight
and one of them is active at night time
now
first reasons that i can't you know for
other reasons i can't maintain this
experiment unless it's outside so so i
i'm not able to explicitly intervene
on that nonetheless
the fact that there is variability in
um
in light
or i could talk about it as temperature
in a natural environment or something
like that right
is
a reason that these things
coexist even though there is no world in
which i can
make them not
say they occupy different ecological
niches somehow yeah no effectively
effectively you know temporal
variability in the environmental
conditions uh produce varying ecological
natures in which each one has a has a
differing advantage
um the point is that i have to have a
model of in my head that says
what would this world be like in which i
could fix
the environmental conditions
that would then produce it even though
that is never actually realizable what
is this world like in which i could make
you forever 25
right
is is the same thing and long enough the
earth will become tidally locked
so so i i'm not sure it's ever not about
a model
i mean for me definitely everything was
relative to a model so i i have
zero problem with that um
sorry and sometimes and so then as
opposed to what i say is an explanation
of reality or is an explanation of this
i mean you know
for for why does why is this zero well
there's a factor and if that factor was
not zero you know didn't hit
hit zero then this thing would this
function wouldn't be zero there is is
the same operation
yeah um
you could you can play the kind of
factual
with the function
you can play kind of actual with the
function but you cannot
play the kind of actual with that
biodiversity that that was said well you
can
you can play the counterfactual in your
head
in my head and i think so so the
argument is all of these are about
counterfactuals in some model that you
have whether or not you believe the
model actually corresponds to reality is
really the only thing that we're talking
about is being different or whether i
can achieve that counterfactual in terms
of bins can i make this actionable but i
cannot use the kind of actuals in order
to validate or falsify my model because
i cannot activate it that's perfect
yeah i guess this this
feels like it has a very similar flavor
to the age question that we had before
right yeah in the sense that uh you
could also say okay what are the
uh what are the set of factors that i i
think stand in between the day night
cycle of the earth right and i this
whatever stimulus the bacteria are
responding to i would i would argue that
don't need to make that
plausibly achievable in the real world
you just need to have an imagined world
where
it exists
uh i i guess what what is the uh
i i may have lost track what what is
what do we need it for
uh in order to maintain coexistence in
order to continue in a constant
environment one of them will go away all
right sorry in order for that to in
order for the uh like the day night
cycle to be a
useful explanation for coexistence
yes
yeah i mean i think that that makes
sense
and
generally it does seem like if you are
explaining things that
have already come to pass
right uh
i i think that a model is sort of a
necessity
at least from sort of the sort of
highly simplified structural causal
model sort of world right um
that is the kind of question where you
would actually need to specify a full
structural causal model right in order
to uh
in order to fully specify like the
probability that you'd like to specify
so
i mean i i think that there is there is
actually potential to formalize this
intuition that like a model is necessary
there
so
i would think that you can have multiple
models right and i only care about the
parts that they consistent the rest i
just leave it for further evidence right
it doesn't have to be one mode right
you're great right
so my definition causality end of
explanation is relative to a model
that i mean that's actually critical and
and now you can disagree about whether
the model is reasonable you can look in
multiple models and say okay it's a
cause in all of these models
but every you know all the definitions
are relative to a single
fixed model you can have uncertainty
about what the model is
right in the epistemic state although i
didn't talk about in the talk
um
you could say well i'm not sure what the
model is i you know one-third probably
one-third is this one probably
two-thirds is that one
it's a cause of both or neither or
whatever
um
i took your question to begin your shot
to say you know what about the real
world and
is it reasonable and and i think this
sort of interesting
tension here a bit between your first
question and and and giles comment that
that uh
um
certainly
nothing in in my definition says the
model has to have anything to do with
the real world
but i mean at some point we would like
to
connect
um
the claims we're making about causality
to the real world so we can ask
you know
are we going to allow all interventions
in a model
what if an intervention is not
realizable in the world
uh
does it still is it still okay to have
that in the model and so on
um
so we've actually
you know now we have a slightly more
general notion of model where we're one
of the features of models and so what
interventions are you allowed to do with
this model that's just part of the
definition of the model but but even in
your one model
world right you have uncertainties right
so you're right you have uncertainty
about the quality so qualitatively
already moving from one fixed
probability distribution to a bunch
i have no problem with it yeah then if
you that's probably share similar
structures but if you go there already
why not also include
different versions of say a card models
right who have similar structures but
maybe a little different
so as i think if you accept that it
could be multiple models even your world
then that means we can have meta uh
multiple models too with different
structures i'm just pushing uh
multiple model wheels
what's the question there yes go ahead
runner is in force um
the first thing i would just observe is
a lot of the things that have come up
when can you intervene on things is that
necessary for causality the distinction
between metaphysics and epistemology of
causation um
are models necessary for counterfactuals
the difference between a model of the
world and a model of an algorithm
there are large literatures on all of
these things and at least i'm happy to
give people pointers to them uh we don't
have to necessarily reinvent wheels here
um
i i guess the question that i i have
though maybe for for both
alex and joe
is
to what extent interpretability
explanation causality this sort of
cluster of notions both of you have very
much emphasized the pragmatic aspects of
it um joe 100 agree up you know um about
that
we are wired to view the world through a
causal lens in many ways um alex you
were talking a lot about the the value
of um action in the world
does that mean that notions of whether
you want to do causality or explanation
or interpretability i'll let you pick
which one you want to talk about um
are tied to the cognitive constraints of
us humans
which is to say
uh is it the case that when we think
about how should we use this maybe i'll
make it more practical how should i as
an ml person use this kind of thing
should i say okay well
people struggle with causal models with
more than about five variables so
therefore i just need to restrict my
causal models in these ways should i
should i be using the cognitive
constraints at all when i think about
interpretability and explainability
i mean which which brings back to
the original question i was trying to
pose i mean
of the cognition or perception
of
of humans in in in those notions so in
terms of i think you know i'm
talking back to my days
with my phd in math i i want to have a
general enough framework where i
certainly want to define causality
and models that are not bounded in any
way the same you know the most 10
variables
for interpretability where now you're
talking about what's you know
comprehensible by humans
it would certainly be a real feature if
you could explain things
using relatively few variables or get a
good approximation
just because it you know
if the goal of interpretability is to
have people understand
people clearly are not going to are
going to have a lot of trouble with a
model with a hundred thousand variables
right
um
that
and but i think that too i mean the
whole point or a major point of our
notion of abstraction
was to say when a small model was sort
of a good abstraction of a much more
detailed model so if you're going to
look at interpretability and say
look i've got this model with five
variables it's not exactly right
but but it gives you the main idea
i i would you know
i would hope that we can make precise
in what sense it's giving you the main
idea
right not just to say well it's close i
mean but but here i mean it really is an
abstraction of of or an approximate
abstraction of this model with a hundred
thousand variables
um
in in this very precise sense it's
really giving you the main idea
right so that that um
if we as as as scientists are going to
push for interpretability and say look
we only want small models because that's
all people are going to understand at
least we ought to be able to make a
connection if we if we
as scientists understand that the small
model
is
you know i mean it's not the exact right
causal model but there's a sense in
which it captures the main idea we ought
to make precise what we mean by that
right that goes back to david's talk in
the morning
that
small model depends on the variables
absolutely and then your sort of big
model
is crucial here which would be a small
model respect to some variables but a
very large model with respect to other
choice survivors
i i
i generally agree with uh yeah
everything that jojo said i think you
know the the reason that i that i
brought up causality in this talk
uh was mainly as an example of a a way
of
distilling a model
down to you know like a scalar value for
example if you're just looking at a
treatment effect
um where we've sort of worked out the
set of conditions where we can
uh map
this summary of the data to
uh a concept that
many people can agree on as being sort
of important
um and you know in the way that that
mapping is
constructed puts a bunch of conditions
on the data generating process and just
the context in which the
uh right in which this summary is is
being deployed
um and so i
i think there there's sort of an
orthogonal question about what kind of
summary you should be pulling out versus
the context in which that summary is
going to satisfy a purpose
um and yeah i i feel like i wasn't
terribly clear in my talk that
what i wanted to do was to say that
causality
or causal inference is at least one case
in which
there's been a pretty deep discussion
about what it takes for that summary to
actually serve a
a well-defined purpose
let me let me
yes go ahead
uh thanks uh so i think it might have
come up in different ways and came up in
the morning uh so some people look at to
think that maybe we look at what counts
as a good explanation or what counts as
a good causal
uh
identification of the cause
and that can kind of unify
many of the things that we want in
interpretability
so i want to get to your opinion in
terms of whether thinking about what
counts as a good extent good explanation
or good selection of the cause or good
selection of the relevant counterfactual
is actually something that unifies our
different aims in interpretability or
actually should push us to pursue
completely different directions so can i
just say ask that one more time
so
here's another way of asking you
asked the question that uh the
experiments where something bad happens
and people focus on different types of
events as either being the cause and
there are similar type of findings in
contrafactual selection so something
happens
people think if only this could have
been different and people focus on many
different things and it turns out that
they focus on things depending on what
their aim is whether they want to learn
from the mistake whether they want to
hold someone responsible whether they
want to blame somebody
i mean interpretable machinery this is
similar in spirit also exactly story
about the car accident right yes
all the economy taversky and everything
that follows from that and the other car
accident yes exactly
so uh
the worry then is that
even when we are focusing on explanation
uh kind of counterfactual causation it
seems like that is kind of under
determined that underdetermines the set
of things that we can choose
we have to add this other layer on top
of it in terms of what can what becomes
a successful explanation right
uh so do you think we can have a general
theory of what that other ingredient is
i maybe this question came up in the
morning and i don't know i'm just
throwing it back there i i thought we
couldn't but maybe you have better ideas
so let me give you a one reason it might
be tough
uh so one thing i've looked at
suppose you have a sequence of more and
more refined models of the world what i
mean by that is you know i describe the
world using three variables and say okay
that variable three if i look at it more
carefully with the microscope i see it's
really made up of variables four five
and six throw out three replace it by
four five and six and you keep getting
more and more refined
and i actually have an example where
um there's a and b is a okaza b
and as i have a sequence of more and
more refined models in a very precise
sense each one is what a logician will
call a conservative extension of the one
before
so that that as i get more refined i'm
not losing any information i'm just
getting more detailed information
what the question of whether a is a
cause of b
flip-flops yes no yes no yes no as i get
further out so in other words as i look
at the world in more and more detail the
answer to the question is a a cost of b
just changes back and forth now i have
conditions on which that doesn't happen
right now i actually have theorems but
that
that observation gave me real pause
i mean not only is it saying that the
way we describe the world
affects how we think about because out
here we're looking at the same events
it's not like in your example david
where we're just describing the world
using sort of different sets of
variables and they're in
so here all the models have a and b
they're all talking about a and b
and they're all asking the same question
as a of cos of b is a equals one cos of
b equals zero or whatever
and the answer
and and each as you're going out each
model further out contains all the
information and precise sense of the
previous model it just goes into more
detail in some sense right um
and the answer flip-flops and that that
makes me really nervous about
what is the saying about causality so
um so i don't have a good answer the
question i'm just pointing out that
here's a technical
issue that that
i don't think has gotten enough
attention actually that that that um
um
what counts you know the answer to the
question is a clause of b is not only is
it model dependent it's model dependent
this horrible way that more and more
detailed models give you different
answers
um
let me just try to
i mean i think here we we kind of again
go to this question of whether we try to
explain the world or we're trying to
explain the model that it looks that the
phenomena that you are describing
is when we try to explain the world and
not so much
when we are attracted yeah we're getting
more and more detailed models of what i
take to be in the same world
and from
maybe to
both of you but there is another aspect
of it if you try to explain the model to
interpret the model it relates to the
issue of of uh strategic
behavior like if we have an explanation
of the model then someone can come and
gain the system
and and try to go against the
change the result of the model for
themselves so it kind of goes to the
question of robustness
or strategic behavior
and
i i just want to uh
pick on this question of how does
interpretability relate to
robustness of the model and to the
ability to to gain the more than
maybe the explanation is the of the
model is changing as
the people are trying to gain the mother
based only so what do you mean more
precisely i
of behavior of understand
no so so say sir you find out that
you want to accept students university
and you find out that the number of
books that they have in your parents
house is a good
yeah
and
so
there's some economist who says you know
as soon as the
um
criteria for decisions become known they
become useless i forget the exact quote
yeah i'm trying to change the focus back
to the implementation of the model and
the implications of jupiter in the model
rather than the difficult question of
interpreting reality
i think you know that there's
antecedents and economics and mechanism
design and maybe like the sort of fair
mail literature is kind of like late to
the party about this literature on
strategic classification i think moritz
was here until recently i was
you know maybe stirred up some interest
in this idea of like
well let's say you're making decisions
and the criteria are known and and the
people subject to like each ex is
actually some person and they have the
ability to manipulate their features and
some cost model and
the
um
like first naive approach is just to
assume that like there's no causality
whatsoever these are just measurements
and there are measurements that are
being messed around with
so it's just totally a matter of like
gaming it's purely like a good hearts
lock kind of thing and then um you know
a next step refinement is people start
realizing well look you know that sort
of
misses the whole reality of how we make
all decisions that we always make like
anyone who actually makes real decisions
whether it's school admissions or hiring
everything does it very consciously of
the fact that people make changes and
some of these are actually
this this is the very reason very often
for making the decision in the first
place like performance-based pay you
know
whatever you know anything like this the
whole point is you you know we we make
decisions for the very purpose that we
know we're
consciously engaging in like uh a world
where there is
strategic behavior
and we want to set a set of incentives
that bring about the behavior that we
want but then
right but then once once we accept that
like what our model is is it's not just
a model in the supervised learning sense
but it truly is a mechanism
then we sort of are brought back full
circle to this thing that we are
modeling
the world because uh if the modeler is
not modeling the world
then they're just stuck in this this
[ __ ] you know what i mean but it's
like it is the fact that like it says
that what it is to actually
operate intelligently in the system is
to have models in the first place that
are whether or not you believe you'll
have the full description of all the
world and i have god's sem in my head
that in some sense my model is
capturing some important parts of the
world such that it leads to the kinds of
interventions that bring about the
things that i care about right
i'm sorry i just want to interject a
little bit um
i just wanted to
bring up there's lots of examples of
what joe is talking about of things
flipping back and forth as you go to
more detail
um we see it in health care all the time
and in fact i wanted to ask about this
so i'm glad you brought it up first
um
we see for example i'll give you a
really simple version
if you have pneumonia
and you have asthma your chance of dying
from pneumonia is less
and
doctors when they see this want you to
immediately fix the model because they
believe that having asthma is in fact a
serious risk factor for pneumonia
then they explain well what happens is
the asthmatics when they come in for
care
one they get to care faster because they
have a doctor who treats their asthma so
they know who to call and then because
they're considered high risk they get
really high quality care
and that's enough that it flips the sign
of asthma from being a very
negative risk factor to now being an
aggregate of positive risk factor
because it causes you to get the care
faster and get high quality care
and then if we add those terms to the
model so that it now thinks that asthma
is bad for you but rapid care is good
for you high quality care is good for
you
then they no longer want us to correct
the model and yet the funny thing is so
this is exactly what you're talking
about one is a more refined model of the
other right because asthma is calling
causing high quality care and rapid care
but the funny thing is they want us to
correct the model that has just asthma
in it because that just doesn't satisfy
their biological understanding of things
but if we don't have the two variables
speed to care and quality of care
in fact the model is
still causal having asthma really does
lower your chance of dying if you could
cure asthma the benefit of asthma would
go away
or you know you know if you could treat
asthma in such a way that it had no
longer an effect on these other things
then the benefit would go away so so it
is truly causal and yet in one case they
like the explanation the more detailed
case and they're happy with keeping the
model the way it is and yet in the other
case the model that's a slightly less
refined version of the model they
actually want us to edit that model
correct it make sure it doesn't do that
anymore and yet statistically they
predict almost the identical thing if
you don't edit them and if you do edit
them they become different
so we see many examples
yeah absolutely i mean i i think right
this uh when when joe was mentioning his
examples i immediately thought about
this this question about causal pathways
um right because you could have multiple
causal pathways that that come from a
single variable that have opposite signs
for
uh the the outcome of interest and then
yeah depending on which mediators you
condition on yeah you can end up with
the remaining like the residual direct
effect
of uh your original variable having a
different sign
and yeah i think this this does sort of
speak to the issue that the variables
that that are in your model
um
really do
define
uh
the
um like almost implicitly right uh
what you are going to call
a cause and effect right so similarly to
our question about age right if we could
identify all the mechanisms in a cell
that are related to senescence and we
could condition on those then age would
be independent of of hair color um
right and so um
right we
i
i i do think this is a really important
point right i think similar your your
definition of explanation
uh
right depends on what the the person is
conditioning on
i think this uh
right this does sort of uh
it all seems to fit together rather
nicely
what's so disturbing about it is that in
one case the doctors are happy with the
model yeah and in the other case they
tell us we have to change them all
it's not because asthma is carrying
the signal of the very decision that
they're ultimately trying to make like i
think the doctors are right
and what you're looking at is that
asthma
is like
he asthma is the confounder of the
treatment
like i feel like this is a problem that
sounds like right like i feel like it
sounds like perplexing but like this is
like a it feels like a textbook in case
of like a case that's given a clear it's
absolutely textbook confounding what's
disturbing
is that
if asthma
usually means you get the treatment
then you should be happy to leave in
that asthma is good for you in the model
because you'll usually get the treatment
and you'll usually then benefit from it
but in that case
the doctors tell us oh no you have to
change
the reason why you want the risk for it
is to guide the allocation of the
treatment thing
and you want that that this means that
azam means you're high risk because
you'll continue to allocate the
treatment like it feels like you just
brought it off like this is the case
where i feel like the dag is really like
the the dag is very important yeah so i
actually our group recently uh put
together a paper that i just found out
is accepted to a kdd workshop um about
this idea that when when we're
producing predictive models for medical
settings where we think that the model
is going to be used to allocate
treatment
um we absolutely should be including the
treatment that was received
as
at least a way to contextualize the
predictions in the model
um right so even if we're not sort of
including in the model
the fact
that treatment was received as like a
conditioning variable if we can at least
include in the model or sort of package
with the model
a
prediction of what treatments this
person would receive
in you know the the training data that
we saw
then i think this this could potentially
sort of solve this issue right if the if
you are delivering a little bit more
context in addition to the predictive
model
um then i i i haven't done the ux study
right but perhaps you would find that
doctors were would be more
uh
accepting of the of the asthma model but
i agree this sort of
highlights this uh very human aspect of
what constitutes a good explanation
so to add to that right at least it's
histobiology our biological system
hasn't changed but then there's a whole
time dynamic right so cancer treatment
something just stopped working
after six months of chemo right so then
we have the world
like changing because of intervention
so then that's a more complex situation
and
it's
a lot more challenging i think yeah i
think that's right
we had a question
did you still have a question
i think i was just wondering um how much
we should also
like look at the dynamics of the
explanation uh because
in that example it seemed like uh
depending on what the model is the
treatment changes so so we should
probably take a model
that that kind of this where like the
the model is kind of stable in what
or like like i i think you kind of
addressed the point already because you
said like we should include the
treatment um
uh yeah and it seemed to be very related
to the strategic um
setting
yeah and i think something else i wanted
to ask before is whether we should
for uh thinking about useful
explanations always assume what is the
action space of the
of the person we are giving the
explanations to so if it's a
if it's a practitioner who tries to make
their model better then it should be
something like what more data should we
feed into it but in other in other
situations when we try to give
explanations to
to people who are classified then the
strategic setting that shai was
mentioning might make sense so
so i i i kind of felt like a lot of what
you were saying kind of
related to that that
for a useful explanation or like a
measure of goodness is the
is the action space of the i i see yeah
so
yeah this is related to car example that
we we we look for explanations
we look for models where we we can
intervene and do something useful
so that
so i think that's right that that
model is more useful if if
it lets me
understand what interventions i can make
that are feasible for me
um
to change the world i mean
that's not the only reason we use models
i don't mean to imply it but but
certainly um
in many real world settings i think
that's true that
you know we're mainly interested in
building models that
allow interventions that that are
feasible for us right
i think that out of time and it's very
exciting and interesting and i hope that
people will keep discussing it
during the reception and the
following days of the workshop and uh i
want to thank you very much for your
talks and for the interesting discussion
and to thank the audience for the
interesting comments and questions
and let's go to the reception thank you
i